[Music]
welcome how's it going everybody it's
been i think a while since i've been on
youtube with you huh i did twitch last
week but youtube of course is
kind of more engaging for me
so i see that a lot of you already in
chat
thank you for your patience we are still
going to have our
tall session an hour and everything but
um i guess the good news for my youtube
people is that
i'm recovered from covet so
that's that's great i did manage to see
my mom that's kind of why i was upset
over the last month
i went through a week and then i kind of
got covered and had to stay for another
two
but
we're all good healthy all happy
i'm well fed right now
um
we are going to have some fun with tall
with the tournaments coming up and
everybody wanting to do more and more
and more
active um games i couldn't think of a
better person than tall we have
plus 200
games of tall
that's kind of um
made it into a puzzle so we're not gonna
run out of it and we're probably gonna
be doing that as like a mini series for
the next few
weeks
so
without further ado
let's jump to it
and
this one
tom is playing as black and
i actually don't know who white is
holmoth
fairly certain i've seen this line
before but
my chest history does not
guarantee me a little bit more
that is true tall was only world
champion for one year but he was a very
very dynamic world champion so
we'll still look into his games why not
so what do we think
let me also do a little
cute
double checking from my end
like to move
and these puzzles even though they're
they're tall it doesn't necessarily mean
that you're gonna look into and find
like super tactics super checkmate super
blah blah because they were real games
it doesn't mean that it's
you just have to find the best move in
the position
and
let me make sure i actually see what i'm
doing
it's for my own sake
nope that's okay wait
uh
that is quite a funny thumbnail i agree
nice
all right so i see a lot few of you
already suggesting
some funny business with your rook
so what do you think
i do have
one
and a half in person
oh i i was dividing
i was dividing i thought that ben simon
would like to divide his attention so i
can't consider that as half
so
i mean i feel like pontics
c6 would be really annoying so
okay
i think i mean if we're considering roth
takes f3 which is appealing
we might as well play
c3 first right
good analysis but what well if you play
rook state rook takes c3 what if uh
whites just plays queen to e4 or e2 i
think e4 would be better but
so
what about the
the youtube land
all right hunter i think you are
you're thinking very critically i like
it
giving me more
um
all right so i guess we're gonna have to
f3 it is
um any oppo any anybody opposing rook f3
no no opposition all right then let's do
it yeah i like our capturing what if
well in the game opponent just took over
here
and i agree because if they take this
now
we could simply do this check
we could also just bring the rook so we
are including a rook as well
and now this is just really great i
could take over here
next i want to do this you can't really
stop it you can delay it but you can't
really stop it because i will continue
to bring more pressure different ways
and this will drop and as soon as it
drops so does the kink so opponents try
to get a little creative and they were
like alright i'm not going to take this
so they did not decide to take our rook
now they're simply deciding that they're
simply attacking our bishop now what do
we do
t3
well the queen would probably have to
move
where do you think the coin would go
so the suggestion is this
and then maybe queen a2
does give this
chance no no don't worry
no somebody's saying queenish dude look
after whoa whoa whoa whoa all right
let's just go back to here
um
i'm going to answer you why this is not
wrong well
queen b2
never mind this works i got roasted
i thought the computer would have
something cool they don't i got roasted
this actually works for black but tall
had different ideas he
um
the super tactical individual that he is
he did something a little bit more
feisty than rick stakes c3 if in your
real game you play drug take c3 you get
a thumbs up from me that's pretty good
what else do we have
i mean i mean we could leave our rook
hanging there and play
queen v8 or one thing
i don't really like this it's too too
back yeah
so what happened to this idea why didn't
you like that
yeah i i because i saw the va more
recently just a
classic mistake uh yeah
i also don't think anybody in the chat
mentions coin takes p5
yeah i mean i don't i want to get rid of
that and
protect the
so you like rock h3
perfect thank you
double thanks
so wait no in the chats there's a rock
h3 suggestion
i don't know where that's leading to
though
i see what you want i see you're trying
to do a little checkmate but they just
take it
if you give check they'll just move away
if you give check they'll just walk if
f3 didn't exist yeah that would kind of
be cool actually
yeah there's a big difference between
taking another
yeah
so unfortunately rook h3 as cool as it
is it does not work
so what else
i have yes doubts
you bring your own tea i do this one is
like
chocolate toffee black tea where okay
where can you find this
that's true
the club has been increasing their t
black tea frequency but
all right
so
queen b5 is actually the the
most interesting one although if you did
play rook c3 pretty good nothing wrong
with it
but um queen takes p5 is a little bit
more i guess
tall like
and oh queen b5 is a little bit more
tall i like that actually
and then you can just play around and
perform this painful checkmate
right
no
did i shock the chats
okay so some i think yeah somebody
wanted to direct g8
so yeah the thing is we we want the
opponent to take this that's why would
we we kind of want to leave that aside
if you play with create you're going to
take this
if you move the stroke well they can't
take it anymore we moved it right so
instead of doing all the instead of
taking this mistake
away from the opponent let's try to give
them the chance to actually do it
if they don't do it all right perfect i
have my extra piece and i'll have my
attacking chances i'm liking this
all right let's move it along
no way that's not the way to move this
is the way
no
all right
again black to move surprisingly weight
actually
this one tall lost so let's look at it
from white
so tall was doing a very cool attack
over here again tall is black but he
lost it so we want to look at it from
white to see how would we beat tall
how do we become taller than tall
when i was a kid i thought it was so
weird that people's last names are like
tall and short and
other things and it was just kind of
funny for me because
i mean mr short is not short at all and
i don't think tall was that tall
so
anyways
i don't think bobby fisher
fished nice one
no it's yeah it was always kind of funny
because in in farsi our names actually
like mean something
when i don't know most of the um like i
don't know the meaning of bobby or
mikhail i don't know the meaning behind
it
uh maybe they're just historical names
but like in farsi my name is pearl and
my last name is bright
so it's like everything has kind of a
meaning
so i kind of like that aspect of my
native language
anywho how did the king gang up end up
on d2 well
one guess is that tall started to go
bananas on it
and the other guest that i would make
which i think is a better guess is that
there was something here that tall i
mean
tall just
recently ate i think
and
for that reason this queen is already
here
so very very surprisingly
this king is actually safe tall's king
is safe
so
an opponent king is not
so what do you think mr passman did
as a white
how did all right moda has a suggestion
of taking over here well if we take that
what do you think your opponents would
do
that is the first thing you should think
about so
good job good start
i'm not going to
the child is silent the young person is
silent i feel like i should start
singing
i'm not going to
although i did get my
karaoke
karaoke karaoke whatever voice back
after kobe for a while there i couldn't
perform
but now i can
but
but the voice was gone so that was a
very good reason not to do it
all right all right so i'm getting a
suggestion of okay take take then what
do we plan to do with this beautiful
queen it feels kind of trapped honestly
do it i know people are seeing it
oh somebody wants to do bishop h6 well i
think the first mistake the first issue
not necessarily a mistake i see with
bishopville six is a take
it's giving you a check so you have to
take and then clean f4 gives you another
check and pick up picks up the rock
so
that's i think the first and
most annoying problem i see with bishop
takes such things
what else you got
so that's uh the username
uh that said rook g1 repetition
i know that's i don't know i'd say sachi
i don't know but i know that's chess
and i don't remember what is
i don't know what's um
gotcha but
kind of make me hungry start thinking
what
those little
what are they
yeah
i know it's written with the g which is
kind of silent yeah
there's a lot of silence ones in there
pretty tasty
oh b5 wait wait wait
oh b3 then bishop f3 i like that the
move that i was thinking about was queen
f1 i haven't finished calculating if
that's the best one but queen f1 i can
do bishop d3 or bishop f3 so i kind of
oh yes thank you i don't know how to say
it though
i'm trying
wait that's not
i can't say it
but they're tasty
now i just need somebody to actually
say it but that's impossible to do with
the chat anyways
yeah so i kind of like queen of one so i
have both
options but
mr postman actually the dirk g1 rook g1
is another a cool one because now you
have bishop d3 and you're protecting g2
because my
uh my suggestion was that
well the suggestion i gave with queen c1
i mean i think it also works but we
don't want to give up our rook i guess
but i mean even even 10 videos have
advantage so
are you ready
go for it oh yeah
i can't say that no
i'm not even going to try
i'll just this this food just will be
remembered as the the italian cool
not pasta thing that has a silent g
people people will know all right
yeah i thought coin phone was cool but
rook g1 makes even more sense and
this queen will be lost
wait actually if we did coin f1 after f5
would that still work
hmm okay maybe not that
yeah now that queen f3 could get a
little ugly
i mean we could be next i mean if you
take take tape we'll be up a rock but
anyways
yeah exactly we could be up a rook but
if we were trying to maximize our
advantage rg1 would be the best one
wait yeah
so that's how tall lost which i think is
kind of cool because i actually haven't
seen that many games that tall loses in
my life
so yeah
all right another one from tall all
right he actually does win this this one
is a little bit longer because um it's
we're not just like sacrificing
immediately whoops
but
we need to prepare for it i know
everybody is seeing some ideas but
the preparation is just as important as
deciding if we should do those moves or
not
so
in the chat what i would like well both
my in-person and um online audience to
do is to just kind of start shooting
moves shooting at your candidate mobs
first
and like don't don't think too much
about it tell me like you're what is
your um
intuition telling you
what's your gut telling you and then
after that we can talk about
um how to modify your gut
well
thank you
been growing him for years
same boat as mine
nice
wait so what happened i wanted
i wanted
not the gut i was expecting for you i
might prescribe some pills i'm kidding
no surgical intervention all right
knight f7 now that's a little surgical
interventions
and
okay bishop before that's another kind
of cool one although bishop before is
not really moving in the opponent's king
direction because our queen is there our
knight is kind of ready
all right so now that's not now that
we've covered um gut feelings
let's start thinking a little more chest
wise so
what does the opponent want right now if
it's black to move what do they want
you figured it out you can block that
and that already gives you a move choice
raymond me too
i seriously do so does my cat actually
he's been having some
small issues too
eating
yeah black wants to eat our pawn in the
middle of the board so we don't want to
give gifts not to opponent anyways so in
order to prevent um
giving free stuff to the opponent how
what do we do
don't help your opponent develop
it's okay it's okay
no no that's good you get to you get to
actually talk out loud and figure out i
didn't like it i know i know i didn't i
didn't release any snakes on you
i'm actually terrified of slangs
but i've grown used to just smashing
them but snakes ah
all right something on d1
perhaps
taking on e6
the reason i don't like it is that my
pawn on d5 is so beautifully
blinding that that b7 bishop making sure
that opponent's queen is just
tucked away so if i take it opponent
will take back with the queen and
immediately is attacking my knight
immediately gaining peace activity
immediately uh developing so how do i
try to
limit my opponent's peace activity slash
development
became a little more philosophical than
psychological i guess
oh it's just on philosophy
i did read about on something on meals
this morning for a class
bishop street yes thank you thank you
for
a few people in the chat who did mention
it
yeah bishop h3 now bishop ishtari it's
such a weird move that you might not
think about it first time you look at
this position right why would you move
that bishop from beautiful g2 to
h3 and your reasoning should be
it would bother opponents it would block
their ideas and it would
make them uncomfortable that's
good enough reasoning for me
chess is a battle you gotta make your
opponent as uncomfortable as possible
legally
and so bishop h3 we were blocking his
pawn from getting uh funny with us let's
say opponent just moves the queen away
all right now they still do want to eat
this but this queen coming just a little
higher is giving me
some ideas
for further development
which before is really winking at me all
right there we go let's say now bishop
d6 because if bishop f4 now i have some
really cool ideas with just putting this
knife wherever i want
to
say a little hello to this queen so for
this test reason bishop d6 all right
now what do we do
that is true now knight f7 is looking a
little kind of cool actually isn't it so
let's make sure um i like that your
first
gut feeling is this knight f7 so let's
just
check the
chest of it and make sure it works
so how do you feel
the other question you could ask
yourself is what would tall do
it's kind of funny because um
i've had games that i was like playing
and i kept asking myself so what would
like this great player do and then i was
like but this this is too dull if i
played like that i would just have a
worse position i would have to suffer
and then i would have to think what
would my brother do and then i was like
my brother is a
tacky
like
crazy boom boom bam bam king
so i actually have done few games and
one um some just because of the mindset
that i tried to think what would the uh
somebody else do
because i wasn't sure what i wanted to
do
so
knight f7 i do like knight f7 so
is there anything that we see is wrong
with it so i agree well
if the queen takes okay that will be um
very pleasant
and if this if uh if they take over here
then i think simply taking on d8 should
be good because this is also falling
and this is also flying so a lot of
things are
getting pretty oh i kind of actually
like this too i don't know which one i
would do actually
hmm
which one should we do
so many things to eat actually let's
just
let's eat this this one is falling
regardless even if they take it then i
can just come back and eat those too so
i like knight f7 first look is looking
cool so what about if they think if the
king takes
the only thing that they they're two and
they're like c6 and d6
ah
e6 and this is
no this is bad i it was a little hard to
hear
yeah so
whoa another fun fun idea with e5 i
think the e5 is definitely interesting
though
it does a little it does open or clean
but i don't want to give this and then
like i don't want to give this chance
it gets a little too interesting i don't
want to do that
yeah if it's if it's something looking
this sharp i kind of want to eat it
already
and
so after take
king moves away
[Music]
and now what should we do
ideas left and right you're looking at
some funny tall games
he won one he lost one
looks better
oh now e5 huh
no queen ideas
i was just thinking about queenie for
what i don't think that actually works
i was just considering queen to a4 check
but i don't think that works
in the first class it looks very
promising
i really wish i had my rooks on e1 and
d1 already
does the philosopher jagger wants it you
can't always get what you want
so
nice
uh is this the game or what could be
played these are actually tall's games
so all right i think people uh
are
really rooting for e5
so i'm actually kind of liking e5 as
well
all right coin open
[Music]
attack over here this bishop is just
beautiful
now yes if took then
i am simply a fan of either right now
rookie one
or queen e4 or just take then rookie one
it's just so many options
and
if i had to choose one
oh i don't want to choose
no if i had to choose one i would take
it and then play rookie one
and
my queen still has some queen a4 checks
queen h7 takes
and i have a lot of ideas that i can try
to
achieve yeah so opponents uh here lozov
just wins bishop of f8 all right now
what do we do
i'm liking it the other one that i'm
kind of truly liking is just getting my
rook involved but i
i think when a seven is actually better
idea
so yeah
and because i have this
because of this beautiful diagonal chick
yeah i agree
and i think opponents
black is just right now trying to
survive even a little longer but
i don't really see that happening
alright how do i finish it off
wait
there's a suggestion in the chat about
something on h1 king
i did not i do not want to self
checkmate anytime soon
rock d1
i'm kind of sure that should work too
but i have something more aggressive in
mind and more delicious
that's what i was thinking also maybe
queen g7
same merits
that's what i was kind of trying to
decide on but tall went for queen f7
i don't see why not queen g7
insurance
yeah exactly palms are delicious if you
can't yeah
so queen f7 um i think it should be the
same if anybody knows why not queen g7
let me know in chat or leave a comment
below
if you watch this later
and okay this is just desperate tries
what do we do
yeah i was thinking queen g8 should we
check me too
night has to come take yeah yeah
yes
nice
queen if someone is more stylish perhaps
perhaps a little more classy
little moro i don't even need your pawn
style sure
all right
well um
this one was very nice i really liked it
again this also does work to be fair
so
exactly 27 also does work and then you
go down yeah yep
thank you pipe and chuck oh wait pop and
chuck i remember you i mean i remember
your username
all right let's move it along we have a
lot of tall stuff so again no
tall is white here and opponent's last
move is knight e5
all right
what should we do
also my other question is why is that
knight on e7
probably ate the bishop there right
where was it to get to e7
probably d5 then
this is too confusing
the king's side really
really i mean truly it's the
it's a little but not that bad
have you watched bones the tv show
remember that the beginning the the
scientists were called squints because
they were squinty
well here's an idea
all right so i would love to do knight
g6
but there are few issues first of all
pawn f takes g6 queen defending direct
second issue knight takes knight tonight
defending the work so
oh that's kind of similar seems like an
anastasia checkmate doesn't it
would um so
a small poll please feel free to leave a
thumbs up or thumbs down thumbs down
thumbs up as a six thumbs down as a nine
wait
yes um
i had a class they had they made us do
this so thumbs up is a six
um did
if i told you guys that i learned
about the name of anastasia's checkmate
and like in the past year and for the
name of fried liver in the past
four years
would you believe me
you would believe me
interesting well our grandmaster in
residence didn't know
yeah
so i guess no nature thumbs up or a
thumbs down
spoiler alert
but yeah it's just such an american
thing i lived in spain i looked it i
grew up in iran i played all around the
europe
35 countries
there was no fried liver fried liver was
a meal when i'm from
and
like
the whole scholars checkmate and
anastasia's checkmate and the only thing
i knew was mother checkmates
and
it was just
whoa yeah a lot of fun stuff
so you technically don't need to know
the names to
be professional or even gets pretty cool
titles like me
so
if you don't know what's anastasia's
checkmate just look it up for the
purpose of it
but you don't need to actually know the
name
what if you had to know the name in
order to play it in a game that was the
rules oh uh i wouldn't want to play in
that tournament
knight f5 and knight d5 i like those
ideas perhaps night night not knight f5
because of bishop attack but i do like
the knight d5 idea good job
right lever e4 e5 f4 wait that's king's
gambit
yes
fairly soon
yeah i like knight d5 good job and i
like it because you are actually
utilizing this beautiful coin over here
so knight d5 good idea queen has to kind
of go to d8 it's literally the only move
that does save the game so
oh mr
presser you're whoa
so awesome
i like knight c7 more though my
reasoning is like
my p6 should also be the same just
knight c7 is more painful
it's like you came from e7 to c7 you're
kind of showing how much you
think little of the opponent and you
just put your knights from one seventh
rank square to another seventh ranked
square
it's slightly more torturous toward um
bothersome
yeah
but i think the legalities of it knight
b6 should be the same because if pawn
takes again we take and this is still
going to be checkmate
why not f4 wait pawn or night
but we we're gonna eat pieces we're
gonna eat stuff let's eat stuff
i had a relatively
oily
meal
a few minutes ago but i can always eat
more pieces it's like snacks
now we do have four all right
sucks cocky wait
i can't
i can't read that strat i'm gonna just
go with strategy
yes the username with strategy something
about chess yeah
only an exchange online exchange what i
want
oh
yeah this is this is like you already
have clear advantage this is also one of
it is also going to drop this is
what do you need opponent's head on a
silver platter this is as good as it
gets in chess
all right
hopefully no kids are watching this
let's continue
feeling good any questions
okay
all right we got another one coming up
no
all right tallest white black made
queen c7 move
now what do we do
why do you need that bishop you're
winning oh we always want more pieces
pieces pawns anything we can eat in
chess you should be hungry chess should
be played hungry
oh
rook takes bishop interesting
recreate
very interesting
so
i see that
to kind of put it in better translation
i see that yeah the chat is kind of
thinking about the placement of these
two pieces and wants to do something to
this right
and that's why queen c7 was a mistake
from black side because they put their
queen and king in a very
edible position
so how do we go about it
i got electric d7 i'm gonna keep my
hungriness
wait the rook d7 rook takes c5 yeah i'll
just do a f7 check and then pick that up
yeah i actually like this rookie eight
is a maybe
but recreate
fake check
move wait the other thing about rookie 8
is what if just take if check
you gotta move this hmm
yeah this is
i mean
[Music]
you could eat more
okay this is winning too i'm not gonna
argue that rukiyet though
perhaps it's not
forced to eat it
what if uh
white is black just tries to help cover
up
this this diagonal instead
i think
i think that rook d7 is a sure thing so
let's just do it
yeah take and we just checked and we
start eating pieces like brownies
all right any questions on this one
should i jump to the next one
all right
i'm liking these
whoa whoa whoa spoiler alert no
all right actually it is black to move
so not much spoilers
but whoa whoa hold on look at the white
position and then look at the black
position white kind of feels a little
more space that a little more activity
so my my assumption is that the move
that white will make
right now queen d4 is a mistake
now why do you think coin d4 is
possibly a mistake
is there anything specific about the d4
square perhaps
true
also the queen is loose
all right let's put all of it together
so you're kind of doing like a triple
pin
wait but there's there's a double which
one with the third one
all right
i do like my d5
yeah and what
oh did you have another idea
oh i thought you said
oh
no no no
and yeah it's a nice e5 and if rook
takes we just take back and we end up
with
extra material and another beautiful
little hello
oh i want to sing that hello it's me
i've been wondering when i can eat more
ponds
yeah this is beautiful
i want to play more games like this
but no so like yeah just looking at this
position white looks pretty pretty cool
right but white made the mistake of
putting their queen well putting their
queen
in harm's way
so even if they don't so that's one of
the reasons whenever i play i try to
deliberately avoid putting my pieces
in loose
squares
like i see that this pawn is under
attack so the first thing that i'm kind
of thinking is f4
i haven't calculated i don't know if
that's the best move but the first thing
that i'm considering is this yes
centralizing the queen attacking the
bishop looks good but the fact that this
bishop is in this diagonal really creeps
me out
what would you play
well i was thinking about f4
and like immediately after i do want to
do like a roxy one
so i guess that's what i'm
thinking about right now
unless you can convince me otherwise
also i think it's probably i'm gonna
flip it uh the fact that i'm a little
biased i love a force like
if i can't do it i will do it
let's let's get a little
extra help oh no f4 okay actually far
not a bad move probably not the best one
because especially for computers f4
looks just
creepy
but no f4 yeah
f4 does work
f6 seems to be a little concerning but
um i guess the other move the i didn't
actually consider this too deeply well
apparently rookie for same idea of
attacking this bishop and just putting
the queen on e2 after i think this is
much more
i guess classy than f4 or f5
so yeah
uh the the issue with rick c1 is that
this pawn is under attack we should not
give up this pawn voluntarily
so we gotta defend this pawn
all right
uh
let's let's continue
okay
tall is white
and the final move of black
b5
what do we do
i feel like i need my evil laughter
button
if you were if you just saw the other
puzzle
this should be already giving you load
chills
well
i think taking with the knight because
we are forcing the opponent to take back
and now what do we do
yeah
and
we eat this right so that's why it's so
important like
obviously black didn't intend to give up
the coin right they just want to trap
the bishop
so perhaps i actually don't know what
was white's last move in this position
but i'm guessing that black kind of like
pushed this
and
black had this idea coming
and white of course saw it
and had this rook set up so i think
white set a trap
that's what would make the most sense to
me because black black spawn on e4 and
blacks just like peace placements is
actually looking very sharp for
tr
trapping the bishop
so i think if black just did a little
bit differently if just this queen
wasn't here this b5 could actually work
so
yeah be careful with your pieces wait
hold on now do it queen a4
a5 work
speaking of that
with the idea of b5
how do we feel about that would that
work
[Music]
yeah then trying to trap it yeah yeah
no you're good i just thought about it
so wait what is wrong with queen a5 okay
bishop d6
what sound completely oblivious
but b4 do you still move the queen
bishop b3
so perhaps not exactly trapping it but
if black intended on trapping coin a5
does oh actually kind of up is the best
middle of the position
so
all right
um yeah again i i agree like it's not
exactly trapping this bishop
but i think coin a5 was a regardless
the best move for
a black
all right let's do one or two more
depending on how strong they are
and
all right this one black to move
and so in this position
white's final move is rook g1
so
we've we've been doing few of these
regarding tall so let's just try to
focus on what changed the root point
from e1 to g1
what changed why do we see that why do
you think
the black managed to win after that
oh thank you troy boy
i like the idea of involving my clean
in one of these two squares i really
wish i could you know do something about
this
it's not exactly a hint it's more of a
wish
so
whoa
vicious fruit fly
the one thing well
the second thing i wish peachy would do
is to actually hunt down fruit twice
they're too small for him
we should have a fishy segment
i've been considering it
i'm going to be taking him some of my
classes next week so
we'll see how that goes
university classes to clarify
this night here also could
get more involved per se
i like the placement of these because
it's kind of giving me some
cool ideas
brooke d4 huh
all right let's say rick d4
the issue is what if queen takes
yeah i don't really like that
actually if the pawn takes my bishop is
still boxed yeah nah we can do better my
to e5 whoa
what if pawn takes
all right guys just because it's tall it
doesn't mean we gotta start going
bananas with our pieces
i don't really see how you would want to
follow up
there so there are less loose pieces in
this position than a few previous ones
that we saw so we can't go as
[Music]
vicious with our pieces as we
did before
how do you like knight b2
i know i just said no viciousness but
pawn to g5 is also i think interesting
but the first thing that comes to mind
is
what if black just i mean what if white
just chills it doesn't really do
anything about it
so it might be too
my idea well i guess tall's idea is
if take
simply check and pick it up
pieces of peace
and if not now we can simply
do this although this might not be as
simple as we would hope for it to be so
if you have trouble finding that to be
hundred percent fair just bring the
knight back to c4
not a problem or even if you wanted to
take knight takes d1
not a problem because you do have a
little advantage you do have the luxury
of
um
not finding the super super grandmaster
move but the super super grandmaster
move
is the queen-ish too the tall move is
the queenish too
and then you're just like all right my
queen is chilling let me just go back
and the idea is if you were to take just
take now the other drug will wait
without the other right sorry king of
two
take and we'll just eat that
go away
and
if king gets you we'll just double check
and we'll just eat so ultimately you end
up with extra material
but then again again again to be fair
knight c4 is a crazy idea
and
even if you do this
your opponents could simply not fall for
your trap and just play
going to d3 now what would we do
very bad coordination yeah white species
are just
all right now what should black do now i
mean i want to eat your queen so you
should probably do something about that
this is so difficult i agree
it's tall what do you expect
i think that one of the most
interesting i guess medical facts that i
learned about tall was that he only had
three fingers
each hand
yeah three and three
so it kind of looked like a ninja turtle
so
i mean to be fair after even after queen
d3 i don't think you actually need to
find a super move all you got to do is
just not lose your queen so just save it
and you ate that pawn so now you
actually have an extra pawn and
opponent's king is just miserable and
the opponent's pieces are just so
crammed together that's gonna make
anybody want to cry
so
yeah psychologically you are winning
material wise you're better your
position is just better
and your opponent doesn't really have
any compensation because there are a lot
of positions and chests that you it's
like you have to find like the exact
move exactly the exact idea this is not
one of those this one's you have freedom
to just do whatever you want within
reason
and keep your peace activity and just
improve your position without having to
worry about finding that exact move and
that's such a
psychological relief because
if you've ever played one of those games
that you just have to find one move one
one move it's so hard to
not break at some point so
the quiet yeah i like that idea too but
no i i think this puzzle was quite
insane
uh
yeah doing knight c4 is just whoa
but again to be fair you don't have to
play queen-ish too immediately you could
simply go knight c4 and i'm taking this
engine just to make sure i'm not saying
um
weird stuff but 94 actually is
just as good
and
now you have the same idea now if
opponent tries to play queen d3 we could
continue with the g5 ideas that was
presented
in the initial position so just compare
this to the initial position right
opponent's played rook g1 and we just
thought we were just like all right i'm
gonna go ahead and eat a pawn we could
just come back now
and perfect
ponds or ponds
so the
the bad idea about rook g1 was that it
gave up the pawn
so that kind of concludes our tonight
class
sorry that you are actually true thank
you benson
my fact checker i thought it was just
three and three
never mind
um
that does actually that's lovely facts
we do conclude our class um i actually
enjoyed doing tall a little so we're
gonna probably continue doing uh the
same ideas
for
next few weeks as well and if you have
any ideas if you have any
recommendations any specific things you
want me to prepare for our future
lessons feel free to leave a comment
below even shoot me an email however you
want
and
yeah
don't forget to take care of your mental
health
have a good night everybody
[Music]
you